kaley cuoco was a season screen veteran
long before she started working as penny
on the Big Bang Theory but even she is
an immune to the odd flub on the set
every now and then here's a look at some
of the funniest goofs from a very funny
career
let's get poppin in a 9th season episode
of The Big Bang Theory Jim Parsons
Sheldon makes a video for crazy future
Sheldon and starts the explanatory video
for himself with some footage of penny
who in this outtake is just way too busy
with her popcorn to care
in another take the camera stays on
Sheldon who makes a wisecrack about
penny penny and her popcorn however
aren't having it for food it's safe to
take it you probably paid for it anyway
oh hi as the script in this season 3
episode was written quill Co spinny
reacts to a comment from Simon Helberg
Howard bye sarcastically asking are you
high at first it's co-star Johnny
Galecki hoof loves his follow up line
are you high you'd have a brother
the director resets the scene and gives
instructions on where to start over but
Coco is still concerned about the Leki
are you still that's not the end my
point is I do not judge a book by hi
[Applause]
doing it wrong
The Big Bang Theory characters hold the
Star Trek franchise and high esteem
throughout the series one would think
that all of that Star Trek stuff
constantly on the set woulda forced its
way into Kaley Cuoco sprain but that's
clearly not the case at least when she's
supposed to be giving Spock's famous
Vulcan salute I am Spock
oh this way another word for Leonard
in this blooper kaley cuoco stumbles
over a word she probably has to say more
than any other in the line of duty
Leonard the name of her characters
neighbor then boyfriend than husband
Leonard Leonard Leonard Coco's blooper
then grows infectious as co-star Jim
Parsons can't get through the next part
of the scene without fudging his own
dialogue the gripping murder of God no
balls balls
not very appetizing in the early seasons
of The Big Bang Theory penny makes ends
meet waitressing at the Cheesecake
Factory while pursuing her dreams of
being an actress to save money she
subsequently exploits her proximity to
the guys by helping herself to their
food as well as their Wi-Fi in this
fifth season episode penny casually
enters the guys apartment to get the new
Wi-Fi password but doesn't seem to
understand what one actually does with
Wi-Fi if you can't get me to stop eating
your food but make sure you can get me
to stop eating your Wi-Fi just a little
teasing the ABC sitcom 8 simple rules
for dating my teenage daughter was Kaley
Cuoco first major role on a successful
show she portrayed the slightly
rebellious and independent daughter of
beloved TV icon John Ritter the kid vs.
adult struggle at the center of the show
becomes comically real in this blooper
from the first season
action yes you can rib kaley cuoco on a
sitcom set but she can give as good as
she gets even to a legend like John
Ritter on the set of eight simple rules
cuoco can't really start her scene until
rigor walks onto the stage and boy is
she impatient
[Music]